[Musique]
le département de la réunion lance le
concours nos gaspille un concours dont
l'objectif est de lutter contre le
gaspillage alimentaires dans les
cantines scolaires des collèges
le classement se fera sur la base de la
prise encore de l'évolution du poids des
éléments des aliments jetés des
programmes mis en place pour la lutte
contre le gaspillage alimentaire
l'utilisation d'une recette miracle
c'est à dire qu'on va leur imposer des
ingrédients on va trouver des des
produits locaux puisqu'il est content de
retrouver des produits locaux dans les
assiettes de nos élèves dont des
produits le code des ingrédients imposés
les mêmes pour les quinze établissements
et l'équipe de chaque établissement
liste devra proposer un menu qui soit le
plus séduisant possible le plus agréable
possible pour que au final lors de la
pesée qui va faire suite à sa
dégustation de ce menu est bien on
retrouve le moins de déchets dans les
poubelles
quinze établissements vont concourir
pour cette première édition de nos gaspi
dans les cuisines des chefs et les
agents des cantines travail sur les
menus et le service afin de limiter au
maximum le gaspillage alimentaire a
aussi
non harmonisées c'est à dire
du leu
/
vraiment baissé sur le grammage parce
que envoyé que
c'était pas la solution de leur donner
beaucoup et qui joue aujourd'hui dans le
monde on
reste un haut niveau on a passé la
formation dans les places et où on a mis
moins de riz moins de 2
nouvelle
des fruits ce qui est produit grâce au
kit en restaurant on a mis moi mais ils
reviennent pensent-ils six enfants
le but c'est ça dans ce collège à
l'etang-salé un groupe de volontaires la
brigade noga spi sensibilise les
demi-pensionnaires sur le gaspillage
alimentaire
ils comprennent que pour gagner le
concours il faudra l'adhésion de tous
afin de réduire la quantité de déchets
après les repas on leur demande
d'essayer de finir leur repas on leur
dit de ne pas prendre 36 mille points et
d'en manger qu'un seul finalement
d'essayer de finir leur assiette bas
s'ils finissent pas de partager avec
leurs amis parce que c'est un petit
geste mais ça fait gros quand même si
tout le monde le fait c'est super
beaucoup de déchets que nous
manger tous les jours
donc je voulais
gaspillage comme ce faire il faut
prendre peut-être un peu moins et se
resservir après les boudins le dessert
partager avec son camarade sur y en a
trop pareil
six noms comme ils ont fait la barre
partager les
si on finit pas à partager les aciers
[Musique]